[Music]
in this video I'll be going over two
methods to delete or shut down a project
in the Google Cloud platform
console projects can be deleted or shut
down by going to the IM and admin
settings page and also from the manage
Resource page before we delete a project
we need to make sure we have the
perquisite IM am roles you need to have
the owner role as only project owners
can shut down or restore projects to
delete a project go to the IM and AD me
settings page of the project you want to
delete and confirm the project name and
ID click on shut down and the dialog box
will appear showing some very useful
information type in the project ID and
click on shut down anyway to delete the
project note that you and other owners
of the project we'll be able to stop the
deletion within 30 days at the end of
the 30-day period the project and all of
its resources are deleted and cannot be
recovered however some resources such as
cloud storage or pop sub resources are
deleted much sooner before the 30-day
period until the project is deleted the
project counts towards your project
quarter you can also delete a project in
the Google Cloud platform console by
going to the I am and admin manage
Resource page search and select the
desired project to be deleted and click
on
delete a familiar dialogue box will
appear type in the project name and
click on shutdown
anyway a project that is marked for
deletion isn't usable if the project has
a billing account associated with it
that Association is broken and isn't
reinstated if the project delete
operation is cancelled after 30 days the
project is fully deleted until it is
deleted the project might still be
visible although it is not
usable please note if there is a lean on
the project that project cannot be
deleted until the lean is removed if a
project has sh
virtual private cloud enabled or has
service projects attached a lean will
block the deletion of the project if you
have the resource manager projects get
permission on the project you can list
the lean applied to a project with the
lean list g-cloud CLI
command Cloud endpoints are special
resources that are considered child
resources under a project this can also
block the deletion of a project where
end points
[Music]
exist